and what we want is the day that I
retire to walk off into the sunset
suddenly for it all to come crashing
down which which is the risk within me
within private equity the idea that you
can put it into into a public arena
where you have proper governance where
you have an independent chairman
independent non-executive directors
where you become more of a cog in the
machine rather than the machine itself
for me it's about creating that legacy
and and ensuring that it survives going
forward and that's why that's why being
in public ownership is really really
important because of course this is a
business that's gone bankrupt seven
times in its history how can you be
confident
there won't be an eighth time what we
mean clearly what we've worked on the 7
the 7 car plan is basically looking back
at history not only to the times of
bankruptcy but also the times of Lehman
shock and saying why did that happen
and essentially you know it's it's MBA
101 when you have a portfolio that's
very narrow and reliance on what market
GT cars in the United Kingdom
you need to broaden the portfolio and
deepen the sales channel so now we're
moving towards 7 cars rather than 3 and
53 markets around the world that we're
in now we're a major exporter and the UK
represents only 30% of our sales now so
you're putting on a lot of new capacity
down in South Wales at the moment is
there a danger that you're going to
dilute the exclusivity of the brand by
producing so many more vehicles I don't
think so because if you think about our
history in 2007 we sell 7,000 vehicles
by 3 cars do the maths as we go forward
we're capping ourselves at 14,000 but
divided by 7 so exclusivity per car is
actually increasing now you think about
we used to sell all of our cars in the
United Kingdom today the United Kingdom
represents 30% of those sales probably
declining over time to more like 20% and
we're moving into countries like China
which haven't had 105 years of
aasta.martin history plus net worth a
high net worth individuals which is a de
17 million people is going to grow
something like 25 million people by 2025
the demand for these kinds of cars is
higher actually fact is these these cars
not just ask them but Ferraris and
Lamborghinis are actually getting more
and more exclusive not less exclusive
now although your peers in the auto
industry are very concerned about brexit
right now
the ability to be able to import parts
as easily at the moment do you share
those anxieties I'm less concerned about
tariffs we're reasonably well insulated
as a luxury group against Tallaght
tariffs we may lose a little bit of
market share in Europe as a result of a
tariff but we'll pick some market share
up in the UK because the tariffs are
imposed hit Ferrari in Lamborghinis so
net-net
it's good we're we're we will be ok
likewise I expect that the pound to to
soften and that's good for an exporter
so I prefer not to have tariffs but will
cope with them if they come but you're
absolutely right the supply chain is the
key we buy about 60% of our parts from
continental Europe we expect supply
shortages we expect parts to be locked
at a port we are increasing our days of
stop from three days to five days if you
think about the weekends that gives us
nine days that we can go with with
without parts longer than that there are
a lot of companies in more trouble than
we are but we also have on standby the
ability to fly parts to the UK the
benefit of being a small manufacturer we
can do that or indeed use alternative
ports so so we're ready we have to be
ready but obviously what we hope is that
common sense prevails amongst the
politicians and we find a better
solution than simply falling out of
breakfast this is the first solely UK
owned and listed car maker for three
decades are you proud of that I'm
immensely proud I mean I entered into
maota world in 1979 this is my 40th year
working in in autos and when I joined it
was relatively easy I lived I live near
Birmingham and the Detroit of the UK if
you want and all of my friends went into
auto and you know over the course
40 years I've gradually seen the demise
of the British car industry we become
very good at making cars for other
people but there were no truly British
car companies left and what that means
is in hard times that there's nowhere
for the kids of today to get trained in
auto there's no career progression
there's no intellectual property and
part of my mission with with Aston has
been to reverse that to be I don't know
whether we call ourselves the last
British car company or the first British
car company but we certainly are the the
only British car company now listed as a
PLC on the London Stock Exchange very
very proud